okay what's going on guys I can't talk
to you allowed it's like 1 o'clock in
the morning and I don't want to serve
the neighbors and it's kind of weird I
don't really do videos like these are
always a little more polished a little
more professional I'm talking in my room
there's my clothes hanging in the back
whatever
so the légion TV show was really really
really good I really enjoyed it but it
left a lot of people baffled and the
reason why is because a lot of people
are used to watching a show like this
what they're used to seeing are like
x-men movies that follow the standard
movie formula in order to understand
Legion you have to read it like oh you
have to watch it like a comic book like
you were reading a comic
well the question is how do you make
sense of all this ok so first things
first
who is legion because i imagine is
probably a lot of people who want to
know what the heck's going on who the
heck is legion ok legion is the son of
gabriel Haller a woman with no mutant
powers whatsoever and in Charles Xavier
of course we know being the more than
most capable telepath and the entirety
of the of the Marvel Universe Emma Fox
was confirmed to be more powerful than
Charles Xavier that was confirmed in
civil war and pretty sure the x-men
Civil War time but the fact remains here
that David Haller is a mutant with
thousands of personalities in his head
each personality having its own distinct
capabilities now the degree of these
powers range by a huge margin everything
from baseline telekinesis and moving
things around with his own mind all the
way up to reality warping on a universal
scale I mean its powers are insane but
each of these personalities have have
their own identities their own wants
their own ambitions their own desires
motivation so on and so forth or
distinctly different people sometimes
they seized control of Legion and
they're the ones that decide what it is
a legion dozen doesn't do but there's
always the baseline David holler
personality who's there somewhere now
the question that people have is what's
going on in the show what's happening in
the show right now okay I don't think
anything we're seeing in this show is
actually happening I think the entirety
of the show so far is in David Haller's
head here's the reason why I say that
there's a couple things that that we
have to kind of get out of the way in
terms of where events take
if it all takes place in david haulers
head then what all is specifically in
his head and what all is going outside
with somebody meddling in his head
because I think that's what's happening
I think somebody's meddling in the head
of David Haller so here's the deal there
have been instances in Marvel Comics
where David Haller is basically
corralled all the different
personalities that he has into a single
location in this story that I believe in
truth I believe that is the insane
asylum that we pick up in where we have
David Haller we have you know the girl
with the headphones the whole nine yards
all those people that we see there are
all personalities in the head of David
Haller you know the fat man the devil
with the red eye or with the yellow eyes
you know those are all the personalities
of David Haller that exists there the
other half was this is whoever it is
it's screwing and David's head so let's
look at something insane asylum first so
the insane asylum was basically just a
home for all the personalities that he
has that's it that's it every single
inhabitant of the insane asylum is just
the home of David haulers personalities
the blonde girl that we saw I do not
think her name it's Sydney I think her
name is Cindy so those guys I don't know
Legion has three three personalities
that are more prominent than the rest
there's Jim Gemayel Kumari there is Jack
Wayne and there's Cindy Cindy is is one
of the cooler personalities they have
but she is probably who the blonde girl
is now the question is if if all this
was happening in his head then where
does like the room with the red table
come into play you know where the guy
that he's talking to you know all I got
to get stuff eventually ending up in the
pool you know that kind of thing where
he goes underwater all the people get
annihilated and he comes out you know
where does all that happen okay so I
think just what what's happening here is
that the flashbacks that we got when he
was a kid when his powers were
manifesting that's real that was the
real world thing somewhere along the
line he did something and he was
basically captured his powers were just
too extreme to control and whoever it is
was messing with his head is trying to
get him back under control it's trying
to help him solve this problem now this
particular show when I was kind of
hoping it would go this way this
particular show bears a striking
similarity to a comic book series that
was called
that was called a comic story and patent
mandatory birth this bears a striking
similarity to a comic book coming back
story that was called age of X and what
had happened here was there was a guy by
the name of dr. nemesis and dr. nemesis
had the idea of trying to cure the
personality though the muscle
personality David Haller had by killing
off the different personalities in
response to this a prime personality
emerged that warp reality no like kinda
cool stuff I don't necessarily think
that exact storyline is happening what I
think is happening and I don't know if
it's Charles Xavier or somebody else but
I think someone's coming along and
they're basically trying to restore
David to normalcy enter the room with
the red table the man that he was
talking to the soldiers with guns all
that kind of cool stuff they're trying
to basically get David Haller to realize
that none of those personalities are
real and the idea is that he'll
basically walk away from that he'll walk
away from all those personality so
basically kill them off by not believing
in them and the result is that it'll
just be the David Haller persona that's
what we get those flashbacks of is huge
because this effort to basically yank
was real away from what's not real
another aspect here is that when he
makes his escape from the from the whole
president all mechanical stuff there's
the whole scene where he meets up with
people that he saw any insane asylum
what question is where they come from
are they there are they not there no
what I think that is is David Haller and
his personalities
resisting the attempts to return him to
normalcy it's him a lying himself with
his personalities as they escape whoever
it is going through and messing with his
head and so when they join you know over
the woman was in the white dress and
this basically them escaping they were
escaping the influence of his person
that's messing around in the mind of
David Haller the other reason why I say
I think these are personalities is
because if you remember the scene
there's a couple things I remember the
scene when David Haller says that he
kissed Sidney and they basically swapped
places they didn't actually swap places
instead Sidney became the dominant
personality and David Haller became the
background personality this is evidenced
by the fact that when Sidney and the
professor start going through the insane
asylum and there's the room where all
the doors are gone then everybody's
locked behind the walls
David Haller is
one of the people who's locked behind
that wall because his personality is
locked away by Sidney the doorman does
the dominant personality now this is
what I think the store begins to shift
and it's this idea that Sidney began to
realize that somebody was messing around
in his head and in response Sidney along
with whoever else was there organized
this effort to free David Haller from
the control of whoever was affecting him
engineering the escape from the whole
facility when they basically got away
from Hoover's messing around in his head
I hope that is a confusion guys too much
but again we're only one episode in this
is pretty stellar in terms of how the
functions what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to write up a reddit post
and I'm going to go ahead and and post
it I think I want to write it in
probably the Legion I don't go to the
Marvel subreddit anymore those guys are
weird they banned me for 10 days because
I didn't cite an issue number on a comic
that's stupid but um I'm going to go
ahead and post it somewhere I'll go
ahead and post some post on reddit
somewhere so that people can see they
can get a better idea because I think
it's easier to kind of type this stuff
out there is to try to explain it off
the cuff but it's one of those things
where I think it's easier to grasp if
you read comics but basically that's
essentially what's going on you know the
kind of wrap this up in an
easy-to-understand way here's exactly
what it is that's that's taking place in
a quick you know 2 minute explanation
categorical water the insane asylum is
david hollers most pure for that is
where all of his personalities reside
somewhere along the line somebody went
in started messing with his head in
response to this the Sidney personality
took over the body of David Haller
became the prime personality and then
began an effort to organize a front or
organize an effort they would see David
Haller removed from the influence of
whoever's messing around in his mind the
person messing around in his mind comes
in the form of a guy who was sitting in
the room with the read table that
basically seems to be what's happening
now it could be I'm entirely wrong it
could be that that's those are actually
real people they're actually they're
that it's just this weird situation I
have no clue where one episode in we
have a handful left until we get done so
anything could happen but I will say
that right now the show is incredible I
think it's going to be one of those
things where nothing makes sense until
we get to the end but uh on hooked
I'm definitely hooked it's it's
certainly pretty stellar anyway guys
we're going to go and bring this to an
end and
yeah I will catch you all later please